bonjour jean de gliniasty et merci de
répondre à nos questions l'azerbaïdjan
qui donne 10 jours supplémentaires aux
arméniens pour le retrait de leurs
troupes
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter ce
nouvel ultimatum ben je crois que
l'azerbaïdjan a gagné ce qu'il voulait
et donc maintenant il peut se permettre
d'être généreux puisqu'en fait il a
gagné donc ilna il n'a pas vous allez
dire à se battre sur des détails de
toute façon il a récupéré ses sept
ces sept districts autour de du haut
karabakh dans l'accord il n'y a pas de
statut sur le haut-karabakh c'est dans
les mains de l'azerbaïdjan donc il a
gagné il peut se montrer généreux peu
non quand vous dites l'azerbaïdjan a à
gagner concrètement qu'est ce que
gagnent et perdent des arméniens est
même question du coût pour les amériques
est ce qu'ils gagnent qu'est ce qu'ils
perdent les arméniens ont raté une
grande occasion
au moment de la visite de lavrov qui en
2016 je crois ou lavrov avaient proposé
leur avait proposé une mouture du des
principes de madrid douilles
il ne rendait que cinq districts sur cet
égard des les deux districts qui protège
le corridor de latchine qui fait
communiqué le haut karabakh avec
l'arménie et à l'époque on s'en souvient
peut-être pas mais la voie ferrée a été
sifflé à la sortie de deux de ses
entretiens quand il avait présenté son
plan en fait les arméniens ont raté une
occasion à ce moment là maintenant ils
ont perdu les sept districts dans l'eure
dans l'entièreté si je puis dire
et ensuite surtout ils n'ont pas de
garanties sur le statut du haut du pied
haut karabakh la seule chose qui a été
dit c'est par l'ambassadeur du désert
badjan à moscou qui a dit que il y
aurait une autonomie culturelle
c'est déjà ça mais c'est pas une
autonomie politique c'est très clair
donc donc l'azerbaïdjan en fait a perdu
le haut-karabakh c'est même si un statut
particulier peut-être pourra lui être
accordée par l'azerbaïdjan est aussi
même si disons la présence de forces de
maintien de la paix évitera de
autour d'eux d'exactions de choses comme
ça
c'est sûrement un exode quelles
conséquences
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une crise
humanitaire alors il faut s'attendre à
une crise humanitaire dans la mesure où
la guerre a été terrible le froid arrive
ces populations ont perdu leurs terres
de sa selle celles qui sont partis leurs
pères leurs emplois et donc il y aura
une crise humanitaire
mais vint le les arméniens sont un
peuple martyr ils ont beaucoup souffert
l'arménie va à nos soins de ces réfugiés
la communauté internationale aussi et
quel avenir pour un cessez-le-feu a été
signé il ya dix jours environ entre
erevan bakou et moscou
on rappelle que l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan se disputent cette enclave
un duo qui khabar depuis 30 ans et pas
uniquement 1 depuis la reprise des
affrontements fin septembre donc cessez
le feu durable ou précaires je crois que
cette fois ci l'azerbaïdjan a gagné 90 %
de ce que de ses bus de guerre si je
puis dire il voulait récupérer le
haut-karabakh ça fait partie en quelque
sorte de de la tâche dynastique 2d alief
on se souvient que dans pas très
longtemps sa armenian je ne pense pas
non je ne pense pas je pense que
l'arménie a subi une défaite militaire
majeure et n'est plus en mesure de
combattre pour récupérer la taxe pour
récupérer le haut karabakh et où et pour
avoir une victoire sur l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise c'est trop tard même
genre de gliniasty vous êtes un ancien
ambassadeur l'ambassadrice d'arménie
apparaît hamsik thomas jane si je
prononce bien s'entretient cet après
midi avec le président du sénat gérard
larcher qui est le deuxième personnage
de l'état français qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de ce rendez vous
écoutez je crois de l'aide humanitaire
mais en termes de droit international
c'est clair que l'azerbaïdjan
conforté par un set
nombre de résolutions du conseil de
sécurité a le droit international pour
lui donc maintenant l'enjeu c'est quel
statut on va donner au karabakh et
comment on va aider les populations
déplacées à survivre l'enjeu politique
maintenant c'est le statut qu'elle
statue l'azerbaïdjan devra haut karabakh
merci à jean de gliniasty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'iris l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques